la gauche n'a pas fait face à gauche qui
désormais légion pour la poule noire à
la défense robert gates a augmenté dans
la vie non pas le faire voilà c'est bon
un
chien
soleil ah ouais mais ça maintenant je
n'ai pas de coupes à tanger à leurs
efforts en quatre jours
wuala
via le quotidien
face au flou
alors eu tard j'ai un frère j'ai certes
pas l'utiliser revient pas sur sa droite
font un tout petit chien d'eau qui joue
un tout petit chou et
il
de lui soufflant la west pour une femme
ne font pas trop fort peu plus tôt
ouattara tous leurs buts et
leur tarde pas à gauche perd pas rigolo
du fort n'ont pas le même de gauche
froid
beaucoup
plutôt bas gauche droite appelle faire
sur part à gauche on la tue pour eric
ella et plus sur sa droite à côté un peu
plus forte à droite très dure
jean boiteux 20
vous faire bouger un peu les vastes
besoins un truc pareil
en regardant le peuple le peuple ou
d'alsace trois jolis seins
c'est du plan seraient vertical ce à
quoi ils parlent pas trop parce qu'on
n'avait pas le soleil donc des vaches et
puis on va sur eux fortement cet axe là
allez après loi tepa pas pouvoir le
faire trop verte
les offres intéressantes à faire des
trucs
c'est beau il ya un truc à droite là où
ces
boîtes ouvertes à droite et rai et
ombres joli
doublé un peu en bas à gauche sabo
ils sont un peu coincé
elles vont suivre la
bataille
je crois qu'on a un autre sens large est
ce que tu veux que ça oui à l'armée de
terre de sang a de la valeur maintenant
je suis juste là de défendre très
nombreux tests assez tranquille
m
de faire un plan serré et est ce que
fait redescendre carrément caf indique
hubert au soleil qui voit parfaitement
fini comme ça où tu ne sais pas tu dois
y aura autant fait en partie car dans
ces colonnes
leur descente sur la gauche ou pas par
exemple et leur demander qu'il comptait
90 degrés à droite ça s'est passé comme
si on pouvait prendre 4 à 10 degrés à
droite
je vais
rien là c'est bien dommage
à cet égard des commandes et à leur
cause des maux même genre mais de
l'autre côté ouais ou dans leur division
quel touriste passé dans la joie et bien
ça pourrait paraître toujours droite
bras droit
pour sûr
bouabdallah
à
des retards
maintenant
de la faire avorter cadre de deux heures
avant à droite
fait que le faire mais la file de droite
ça marche pas avec les raids là je vais
les avoir
fait pas si grave que ça a aidé par un
autre chapeau qu'ils ont passé ce
quartier récent cd en
fait pour les gens pressés qui
flamberait de paillettes et a raté pas
ça les jambes on veut monter soit réduit
alors quand ils vont tourner regarde
en fait les frais à l'e3 rappelle
pourquoi manière bizarre
elle était droite et voilà c'est ce
qu'ils font d'ailleurs voilà c'est bien
voilà dix ans par toutes voies
ah ah
à bâle ça dont je trouve
c'est rigolo ça devient beaucoup plus
rigolo
jean-paul voilà
dans les gens plus pour la lp2 outre à
la tête des bleus
l'app est derrière derrière il ya des
têtes pour près des trois
j'espère bon c'est bien beau tout ça
fera pas
le bordelais pâte avec eux
espacées
on revient verticale pour
cela que leur est pas attendre en prix
asics
arch
vadim a récupéré deux pas dans la poche
la gauche en tête pendant 7 à gauche au
pérou
battu avec les partout
les gens sont à 40 chevaux de paso doble
pour le porte à porte classique ce soit
ça soit pas
traitée sur un pied tu vas voir des
chevaux vierge
pour tes ans
google docs